joining us now are two parents who've
been on the front lines protecting our
kids and advancing real excellence in
education azan omani senior contributor
at the federalist and ian pryor former
doj deputy of public affairs and senior
advisor for america first legal ozra
we'll start with you are three four and
five-year-olds even thinking about this
kind of stuff and why is this in the
public school system
this is what they're thinking about a
little unicorn an innocent unicorn but
our unicorn is no longer the unicorn
that they're teaching in schools this is
what they're teaching oh i owe the
gender universe how cute i love ozra has
a prop that our camera is going to try
to
zoom in on but it might be a little
difficult isn't that no don't turn it
around okay right there okay so these
are the questions laura you can i don't
know if what is your gender identity for
a preschooler and a kindergartner
are you on the scale from female woman
or girl man boy or other
and then what is your gender expression
your sex assigned at birth your
physically
physical attraction and then your
emotional attraction i mean these are
words that kids can't even understand
but in fact from
california to massachusetts this is
what's happening they're not only going
after our kids minds but their bodies
now ian given everything that you
advanced in northern virginia uh loudoun
county we saw the explosion of the
controversies there
what's next for parents in these fights
because they're doubling down on the
left on this radicalism well you know i
think it's really interesting we've seen
a lot on the gender issue and parents
have a 14th amendment liberty right to
be the primary decision makers for the
health welfare and education of their
children and what you're seeing is that
schools everywhere are completely
disrespecting that they're saying you
don't get to know about your child's
gender identity unless the child gives
us permission to tell you here you have
in maryland where it's okay if you're up
until third grade you can't opt out but
after fourth grade you can well that's
an equal protection issue right there
and what is the compelling government
interest that they need to have they
won't tell you but their interest is we
need to get to them when they're young
before they have fully developed brains
and can look at this and say wait a
minute this is ridiculous now fairfax
county public schools
now are considering a new rule
suspending students for malicious
misgendering
so
suspending students and apparently the
offense carries with it a suspension of
up to five days
if frequency
and intensity are present azra yeah i
mean this is it this is their new
you know track changes in their new
policy and in that they slip in this
this punishment for malicious
misgendering i mean just unbelievable
because a child
has you know
childhood right to discover to learn not
this kind of punishment that's basically
policing right but meanwhile the
language meanwhile in their lowering
academic standards at the same time so
you have the malicious misgendering
rulemaking and then you have a lowering
of academic standards lowering the bar
for everyone so these are the two
competing
bad influences on our kids that's right
and not just lowering academic standards
but discipline standards so all across
the country you're saying well we need
to close the discipline gap so all these
things that we're not going to suspend
kids for being disruptive in class we're
not going to suspend kids for for things
that they normally would be suspended
for but if you misgender someone now
we're going to start the you know school
of prison pipeline on that one that's
more indoctrination that's more of the
propaganda from the beginning now for
seventh graders in maryland if people
think i'm exaggerating here the sexual
health section of this new educational
framework for the curriculum
says identifies many different sexual
practices with possible outcomes of each
azra again i'm not going to read um all
the sexual practices people are pretty
familiar with those uh
what this is bizarre and it's borderline
abusive yeah i mean the term grooming
has become part of our vocabulary
now what does grooming mean grooming has
been
i looked it up today and it is the act
of having inappropriate sexual
conversations with children for
preparing them for sexual acts and this
is
you know unacceptable and unethical in
society it's shattering innocence of
children is it not shattering their
inner sense but all of these books here
that i've brought you know let's talk
about it which it tells kids to actually
go online and find like-minded people
with the same fetishes that they've got
what grade is that for this is for
seventh to twelfth graders so
unbelievable so this is telling the
public school system it is in the public
school system i got this in the public
we don't have time to go through every
dog and you know what we can't even show
it on tv because it's so unacceptable
and so much of it of these books a
parent tries to read excerpts yeah at a
school board meeting and the parent is
shut down for trying to provoke you know
a a you know an
absolutely incensed reaction among
audience members attendees of the school
board meetings but the kids can read it
those guys thank you so much for your
work on all of us great to see you thank
you thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else